神かなりビッグなゲストですよゲソというサーフィン出来てるねこれをキックコメント
でいいですよいいですよと言われてたシャーペンです
スマッシュです外見はこんな感じです
まあ特徴的なのはデー先がここが4mm でこの
キャンプがないけど一体がしているところですちょっと飛び出てる
ラバーグリップに黒いですね
俺はな
スムースんのことはあんまり知らない押す場所ブラザーズか知らないけれどもこの
スマッシュはツッコミてはやばいです多分
トップカーだと思いますサーフィンではそうこれ
俺多分これ使うは話キック酒でも良さが伝わるという異常なキャンペーンなんですよ
ショッピングサイト amazon の best of 2013年間ランキング
筆記奥で1弾アゾンの飛距離で一番売れてますこのシャーペンペンテルさんの
シャンペンでございます前回の入ったと思うんですけどぺんてるのパパいいかで弾
jal とでスマッシュも
スマッシュをして帰ってないですねなんでもないです
これつれ1986年発売だから28年4半世紀のウィングセラーということになって
おります
これがはてますけどねはい寒気してきたもなんか昔は結構やすいシャーペンが売れたら
いいですが100円とか200円ともそのときでもこれは1000円だったんですけど
それでも売れてたと言う
結構良いショップだのブラシです例えば昔なんですけど1987年にはグッドデザイン
賞教育用品部門の大賞を受賞しています
なんかでなんといいんだよ見た目のみなさんに覚えておいてほしいんですけどこの体型
の3名はこのハッセル部分があるじゃないですかこのキャップの上の部分
9外れる部分これを
この外れるここを口金と呼びます覚えておいてくださいドクターグリップとかねまぁ
大抵のシャーペンもこの
クレクレクレってここの汗んですけどスマッシュに感じじゃないですか釣れた個体が
一体化していますずんですよ
書いててすごい方からそういうやつないですかブレるというか安定しない
もうその要素はゼロなんですよ最強の安定感を持ってかけませしますこれやべーなはし
てそして低重心です
通信がん
あーうん止め壊れないでえっと通信なん
オールド点がおかしい now
プレイ0ん
ほらん
なんでもないです下の方にあるのですごい書きやすい
まあそうや晴れですね真っ黒っていうデザインが何か言いです
だからたどり着いた感じがありますちょっと僕自体あんまり情報は少ないシャーペン
なるというマイボ説明できないんですけど
絶妙な感じでロングセラー花園リア原木弾バーンということで実力者というかもう簡単
に結果が出てる車10年
新発売ボタンでもないかしかロングセラーのシャーペンなので
明日で人も多いと思うんですけどだが今その後についての詳しいんだけどとりあえず
書いてみますじゃあこれやば会なんかも最強感の漂ってよっしゃーかけます
メッツが来やすいんだけど
なんかあれだなぁ書きやすいつ書きやすいんですけど製図用独特な押せゴーヤしっかり
可決は完全石字汚いんですけど字が汚いたちが来たラック
掛け算みたいなふっ綺麗な人は綺麗にかけるみたいな実力が発揮れるサーフィンねこれ
何言ってたらいいねぇいいねぇいい時もドクターグリップを押すことがちょっとおっ
あんまりはっきりできなくなってきたようです
受験生これは買いですこれはもう本当に1日20時間くらい勉強できると思うんで
これはおすすめです勉強のやる気がでもうね俺もべきださになったけどしないよ
なんかずっとも家を借りてたくなる
やばくねこれましてもう冗談だけじゃないぞ
おいこの動画見だしたお前等よかったら東大工学をレート
def